Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
mortal kombat movie ending and credit scene video
also explain what they've said about the sequels
there's obviously clear setup for what's happening
in the next movie but they have multiple movies
planned that they've talked about so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos obviously careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the movie yet because we're
talking about the ending and everything that
happens during the film all the easter eggs but
you finally get your big answer about johnny cage
where he was during the events of this movie and
why they weren't hyping him up until the very end
of the film so i'll explain what the director said
about johnny cage himself as well as some of the
other characters and some of the other actors from
this film like sub-zero the person who plays him
said that he was signed to a five movie contract
just giving you an idea for how they're plotting
all these films out but the whole thing with
the movie is that they actually don't do the
tournament itself that you would expect them to
do like they did during the events of the original
mortal kombat movie in 1995. it's meant to be more
of a prequel movie so the writer and the producers
explained that they developed this arc as a
trilogy of movies the first one supposed to be
a prequel world building introducing some of the
core concepts and characters like you learn about
the tournament they talk about it a lot through
the pov characters which are mostly the mains
from earth realm and mostly the cole character who
is scorpion's descendant and whose powers although
a little bit different bears some similarities
to the hellfire that scorpion wields he unlocks
most of his special powers but you don't see too
many crazy fatalities from him like almost all the
characters do a version of one of their fatalities
from the video game series most of the characters
in the video game series eventually learn multiple
different fatalities but towards the end of the
movie shang tsung uses cabal to tempt kano to turn
against raiden and the earth realm champions and
lower the protective enchantment that he raised
around the temple of light to prevent shang tsung
and his champions from outworld from killing all
the earth realm champions before the tournament
could actually begin as a way to circumvent this
big prophecy involving scorpion the whole thing
with the prophecy is that when the movie picks
up in present day raiden says the earth realm
has lost the last nine tournaments to outworld and
if they lose the next one that's coming up in the
sequel movie mortal kombat 2 or whatever they
decide to call it per the traditional rules of
the mortal kombat multiverse via the video games
outworld will gain control of earth realm and even
though they don't explicitly say this in the movie
if that were to happen the ruler of outworld xiao
khan who you see images of during the movie and
statues a couple times but he himself probably
won't appear on screen until the sequel if they
win the 10th consecutive tournament shao khan
will be able to merge earthrealm with outworld
and expand its power there's a lot of arguments
about whether or not shao khan is an actual god
he's not a god in the same way that raiden is a
god but he's about as powerful as raiden and he's
ancient just like raiden but shang tsung is able
to kill a couple of the earthworm champions so
press f in the chat to pay respects to kung lao
and even though kano switched sides sonia blade
winds up killing him to take his mark making her
the next earthrealm champion even though he
was a bastard technically he was a member of
earthrealm's champions they get kind of crazy
with it because bihan for instance the sub-zero
character was originally one of the earth realm
champions back in the 1600s before he became
full sub-zero but then at some point he turned
sides and became a champion for shao khan so the
same thing happened with cabal's character because
he said he had history with kano like they knew
each other from earth in the whole twist with kano
switching sides is also meant to be a reference to
the video game series because technically he
is one of the antagonists from the video game
that you fight and in the original mortal kombat
movie of the 1990s it's kind of the same dynamic
kane was probably one of the best parts of this
movie he stole almost every scene that he was in
but the whole third act of the movie is basically
shang tsung's champions goro subzero cabal raikou
molina nitara shang sung himself invading the
temple of light as the earth realm champions are
still trying to learn to unlock their special
powers slowly with a lot of fatalities from
the video games they are able to kill all of
shang tsung's team the reason why they say the
scorpion versus sub-zero fight where they hype
it up so much is because they're kind of going
with that video game dynamic of the way they
plot the fights out and sub-zero is meant to be
the final boss of this first movie not including
shang tsung himself because he is more powerful
shang tsung doesn't really fight during the film
like when kung lao challenges him he just says
you're beneath me you're not worth my time and
says nitar after him because in the video game
series shang tsung is meant to be the final
boss of the first tournament arc so that part
of the movie was just a clever wink at that like
he's saying i'm not going to fight until someone
on your team defeats all my champions in the
tournament during the sequel movie it was the same
situation in the original 1995 mortal kombat movie
with liu kang not really fighting shang tsung
until the very end of the film and shang tsung in
this new movie does act similarly to classic shang
tsung he does kill people he does use his sorcery
to steal kung lao soul just like he stole souls in
the original movie but in that final boss fight
cole takes on sub-zero after he goes him into
a fight using his family trapping them in that
mma facility the gym where he fights all of his
fights earlier in the film not sure why sub-zero
decided to take his family there of all places
but they actually turn the gem into a full version
of sub-zero's lair from the video game series like
his level from the original mortal kombat video
game the fights were all pretty fantastic pretty
bloody during the film but as you would expect
he kicks cole's ass until he instinctively grabs
scorpion's original dagger that was given to him
by raiden earlier in the movie and even though
they don't fully explain this part he uses it
to summon scorpion from the nether realm so the
nether realm is the part of the mortal kombat
multiverse that's supposed to be like their
version of hell but is just a separate dimension
a separate realm like earthrealm and outworld
are separate realms of the multiverse cole had
been getting visions of scorpion throughout the
entire movie asking for him to release him without
really understanding what it meant and over the
centuries in the nether realm scorpion had learned
to unlock his powers like you see everyone doing
earlier in the movie they also explained the
fire he wields is hellfire from the nether realm
because technically he is undead now but he and
cole tag team sub-zero who presumably has been
kept alive this whole time since the 1600s through
shang tsung's magic and his own special abilities
both he and scorpion were originally marked as
champions of earth realm they both had the mark
that's why they have special powers then scorpion
uses his fatality from the video game series
from the first mortal kombat video game killing
sub-zero with his fire breath his head doesn't go
full skeleton like it did in the original game
but you do see a little of the skeleton there
he thanks cole for freeing him and asks him to
protect his bloodline then presumably returns
to the nether realm they didn't say how many
movies were on his contract the actor here but
of course i think scorpion will come back in the
sequels he was one of the best parts of the movie
why wouldn't they bring him back if they're going
to be bringing sub-zero back in four other movies
but then shang tsung enters and claims that he
has many more fighters where these ones came from
which is a reference to the much deeper roster
of characters from the video game sequels like
mortal kombat 2 mortal kombat 3 then says death
is only another portal like death is not the end
sending sub-zero and goro's bodies back to
outworld so if you have not played the video
games that's meant to be a reference to sub-zero
becoming noob saibot in the video game series
after the original sub-zero was killed in the lore
he was turned into a wraith in the nether realm
becoming noob cybot who was a secret unlockable
character during the second mortal combat video
game so this is them just teasing that he's gonna
come back as that character in the sequel and the
actor who plays him who was fantastic obviously
said he was signed for five movies here's the
thing though remember how i said the writer of
the film said they were developing a trilogy what
are those other two movies on his contract would
it probably have plans even though they haven't
talked about it explicitly to do a movie just
based on sub-zero's story like do a sub-zero movie
all about him just said during a different part of
the timeline because why wouldn't they try to take
this to a very marvel cinematic universe place
where you do a bunch of interconnected movies
apart from the main franchise like you assume the
avengers movies are the basic main franchise in
all the solo movies are kind of like the spin-offs
so they'll probably try to do spin-off movies for
know if they're actually going to get into the
crazy cosmic level stories anytime soon because
it just sounds like by the end of this trilogy
in the franchise they're mostly just covering the
initial tournament arc and shao khan's invasion
of earth it's a little early to say whether or
not they're actually going to get to that third
movie but i think for sure they will make the
sequel also everybody leave your suggestions
for who you want them to cast ask johnny cage
in the comments everyone click here to re-watch
that opening scene for my other mortal kombat
movie video and click here for my full marvel
falcon and winter soldier episode 6 finale video
thank you so much for watching flawless victory
everyone and i'll see you in the next video!